bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir les temps
forts de la dernière session
parlementaire aujourd'hui et bien place
à la deuxème partie de la réforme
territoriale le fameux projet de loi
notre nouvelle organisation territoriale
de la République ce texte qui réparti
les différentes compétences en fonction
des échelons du territoire commune
intercommunalité département ou encore
région un texte qui a vu l'opposition du
Sénat au gouvernement sur de nombreux
points je propose aujourd'hui de nous
intéresser à deux points tout d'abord et
bien la politique de l'emploi doit-elle
être confiée aux régions et bien selon
les sénateurs oui au contraire le
gouvernement plaide lui en faveur d'une
politique au niveau national vous allez
pouvoir voir les discussions sur ce
point également deuxième point sur
lequel il y avait une friction entre les
sénateurs et Marie-Lise Lebranchu et
bien le mode de scrutin pour les
conseillers communautaires mode de
scrutin qui devait être au suffrage
universel direct et au niveau de
l'intercommunalité c'était pour les
sénateurs un pas vers la disparition de
la commune et d'ailleurs finalement et
bien ils ont obtenu gain de cause sur ce
dernier point tout de suite donc retour
au débat dans
l'hémicycle article 3
bis alors j'ai une demande de parole de
Monsieur le Ministre delb vous la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues avant les articles 3 bis et 3
TER je voudrais rappeler qu'en première
lecture le Sénat a été à l'origine de
l'ajout de disposition visant a confié
aux régions de nouvelles responsabilités
en matière de coordination des acteurs
des politiques de
l'emploi objectif affiché de permettre
une meilleure adaptation des politiques
d'emploi aux spécificités
territoriales l'objectif est louable il
est partagé c'est la méthode qui pose
problème vous le savez la lutte contre
le chômage et pour l'emploi sont des
compétences
régalienes pa emploi est l'outil majeur
des politiques de l'État et son
opérateur exclusif
la rédaction issue du Sénat venait
ajouter une tutelle de la région sur
Pôle emploi c'est la raison pour
laquelle nos collègues députés ont
largement réécrit l'article 3 bis
introduit par le Sénat de façon à ne pas
remettre durablement en cause le rôle de
l'État dans la lutte contre le chômage
et à garantir la suprématie de PO emploi
dans le service public de l'emploi je
rappelle que la fusion de la NPE et des
acédiic s'est avéré suffisamment
délicate pour ne pas en rajouter par
contre la mobilisation des régions sur
cette question est essentielle car elles
sont compétentes en matière
d'orientation professionnel de formation
de développement économique les régions
doivent être au côté de l'État pour
élaborer une stratégie régionale
coordonnée en faveur de l'emploi au plus
proche de la réalité de la situation
locale du marché du travail et c'est
bien l'objectif de l'article 3 TER qui a
été ajouté à l'Assemblée cet article
permet à l'état de déléguer aux régions
qui le souhaite la coordination de
nombreux acteurs du service public de
l'emploi hors po emploi en vertu d'une
convention avec l'État garantissant la
cohérence avec les politiques et les
dispositifs nationaux or la commission
des Lois du Sénat rétablit sa rédaction
de première lecture les modifications
apportées par la commission des lois sur
les articles 3 B et 3 TER pose un
certain nombre de difficultés remettent
en cause la cohérence même des
politiques de l'emploi et de formation
d'une part les dispositions conc
concernant le créphob comité régional de
l'emploi de la formation de
l'orientation professionnelle remett en
question la nouvelle gouvernance
quadripatite mise en œuvre par la loi du
5 mars
2014 qui associe l'État la Région les
représentants des salariés et des
employeurs le président de Région ne
peut exercer seul la présidence du crfop
l'association des pouvoirs publics des
partenaires sociaux est un élément
essentiel de la réussite des politiques
d'emploi et de formation d'autre part je
rappelle que les dispositifs de la
politique de l'emploi emploi aidé offre
de servicees prestations de Pôle emploi
et pour partie des autres secteurs du
service public de l'emploi pilotage des
moyens de Pôle Emploi sont des
dispositifs nationaux comment les
acteurs dans les régions pourraient-ils
s'engager sur la manière dont il
mobilise les outils des politiques de
l'État sans l'état enfin il me semble
risqué d'avoir une logique
d'intervention différenciers en fonction
des publics cibles l'état gérant les
chômeurs de longue durée et les régions
les populations employable ce que laisse
présumer le dispositif proposé par
l'État c'est la raison pour laquelle le
groupe socialiste soutiendra les deux
amendements du Gouvernement qui
rétablissent l'équilibre obtenu en
première lecture à l'Assemblée merci de
votre attention merci mon cher collègue
amendement
270 qui va être défendu
par ou madame Pruno madame Prun oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre et chers collègues
le service public de l'emploi est-il
soluble dans la
décentralisation c'est cette question
que l'on peut se poser sur l'article 3
bis voulu par la majorité du Sénat au
motif que les compétences de la région
en matière de formation professionnelle
et
d'apprentissage serait la condition
nécessaire et suffisante pour y
adjoindre le service public de l'emploi
à la vérité la situation générale de
l'apentis en France et les limites de
l'efficacité de notre système de
formation permanente encore fort éloigné
de la mise en œuvre d'une forme de
sécurité sociale professionnelle semble
montrer à contrario qu'il convient
d'avoir quelques précautions en matière
de
régionalisation ce qui est en cause à P
emploi ce n'est pas de notre point de
vue de savoir si le fait de régionaliser
son activité R l'institution plus
efficace mais c'est bel et bien de
constater que la fusion ANPE acédiic
réforme du quinquena écoulé a conduit le
service public de l'emploi sur la voie
de grande difficultés pour ne pas dire
plus l'évidente faiblesse des effectifs
de Pôle emploi la précarisation des
agents de l'institution l'incapacité qui
leur est fait de réaliser un véritable
suivi et d'apporter de véritable able
conseil au privés d'emploi les exigences
statistiques régulières tout cela
conduit à détériorer gravement la
situation de
l'institution et malgré toutes ces
difficultés pour l'emploi s'avère plus
efficace que n'importe quel autre
organisme de placement de privé d'emploi
il nous semble qu'il vaut mieux
supprimer cet article dont la dimension
purement déclarative est assez
évidente le vrai sujet en la matière
chers collègues réside en effet plutôt
dans l'accroissement de l'effort en
faveur d'un service publicque de
l'emploi performant assorti d'une hausse
de sa subvention de fonctionnement et
d'une réflexion nécessaire sur la
séparation entre traitement de la
demande d'emploi et instruction des
allocations chômage c'est pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons que nous vous
invitons à adopter cet
amendement merci ma cher collègue avis
de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur 70
oui nous considérons bien sûr que et le
propos de
Monsieur le Ministre delb nous a pas
vraiment surpris mais un petit peu quand
même bon oh oui bon mais ça c'est normal
nous nous sommes beaucoup plus offensifs
en matière d'association des régions sur
la politique d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi nous avons regretté on nous
annonçait 3è étape de la
décentralisation et on nous présente une
loi d'administration de la République
alors peut-être que ça viendra un jour
mais nous on a dit on va
anticiper nous paraît évident que les
compétences qu'on a donné au région en
matière de formation professionnelle la
compétence que nous avons voulons donner
en matière
d'économie nous nous aurons aussi un
amendement sur l'enseignement supérieur
meilleur association des régions au à
l'enseignement supérieur bah c'est
bancal si on ne met pas dans le la
boucle la région pour l'accompagnement
vers l'emploi et c'est ce que nous avons
proposé en première lecture
d'ailleurs chacun se rend compte que
c'est sans doute une nécessité puisque
le gouvernement lui-même et et et nos
collègues députés ont dit on pourrait
faire des expériences des
expérimentations d pourquoi faire des
expérimentation puisque on veut donner
aux régions des compétences en matière
de développement économique on l'a donné
en matière de formation
professionnel il est évident que il faut
donner aussi des compétences en matière
d'emploi nous avons été extrêmement
prudents d'abord nous sommes tenus par
des règles constitutionnelles vous les
connaissez c'est l'article 40 et et
deuxièmement nous ne remettons pas en
cause l'établissement public qui est
chargé de l'emploi en France mais on
souhaite que alors si uniquement c'est
avoir un représentant de plus des
régions au Conseil national de Pôle
emploi c'est un petit peu faible he
comme implication des régions donc voilà
donc il y a une ceux qui n'en veulent
pas bah ils n'en veulent pas mais nous
nous maintenons que c'est certainement
et nous continuerons à à à promouvoir
cette idée qui nous paraît extrêmement
importante donc tous les l'amendement de
suppression bien entendu de ce point de
vue nous pouvons y être
favorable madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement sur le
270 défavorable madame la
prés
défavorable très
bien vous maintenez votre amendement mes
chers collègues il est maintenu donc je
vais le mettre au voix je n'ai pas de
demande d'explication de vote deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté quatre amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 659 du gouvernement madame
la ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente j'entends
bien ce qu'a dit à l'instant monsieur le
rapporteur puisque nous avons regardé
les travaux de la commission des lois
bien
évidemment nous ne sarions pas arrivver
y compris au contenu de l'amendement que
le gouvernement dépose qui est
effectivement un retour au texte tel que
votter à l'Assemblée nationale nous n'y
serions pas arrivés s'il n'y avait pas
eu le débat au Sénat c'est parce qu'il y
a eu un débat au Sénat et des
propositions dans le cadre de votre
Haute Assemblée qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons pu en travaillant
avec mon collègue françoissamen sous
l'autorité du Premier ministre trouver
un certain nombre d'accords
qui nous semble répondre à une volonté
d'équilibre concernant cette ce dossier
difficile le service public de l'emploi
comment effectivement y associer les
régions sans déstabiliser le service
public de l'emploi dont je rappelle
toujours qu'il a été totalement
réorganisé il y a quelques années sous
l'autorité du ministre Gérard Larcher à
l'époque rassemblant dans une même unité
à la fois ce qui est disc au niveau des
partenaires sociaux les assédiques et
puis les personnes chargées
d'accompagner les chômeurs effectivement
même si on ne peut pas imaginer
transfert de ce qu'ut étaé la NPE
globalement c'était tout à fait
différent dans la discussion
et certains en ont largement convenu
nous nous voulons effectivement partager
et je répète grâce aux travaux du Sénat
la volonté de la socié des région plus
étroitement à la conduite des politiques
de l'emploi parce qu'elles sont des
acteurs économiques majeurs vous l'avez
rappelé elle dispose de compétences en
terme de formation professionnelle
continue sans doute monsieur le
rapporteur ce qui nous a manqué c'est et
c'est parfois un regret je l'exprime ici
en toute
amitié c'est que on n'est pas pu
transférer la formation professionnelle
dans ce texte et qu'il a été qu'elle a
été transférée dans un autre texte qui
n'était pas celui de la décentralisation
mais qui était celui de la réécriture de
la formation professionnelle je pense et
je continue à dire qu'effectivement
c'est plus difficile comme ça de se
souvenir que il y a quelques mois
seulement on a
décentralisé une compétence extrêmement
forte à la région qui est la formation
professionnelle c'est une
décentralisation portée par un autre
texte que celui de la décentralisation
et du coup c'est vrai et du coup c'est
vrai
monsieurest nous n'avons après s pu
porter que l'organisation territoriale
de la République c'est peut-être une
erreur de communication dans notre
écriture mais c'est ainsi donc et je
rappelle que les régions et vous-même
dans votre expression concernant
l'accompagnement des chômeurs souhaitait
que la formation professionnelle soit
transférée le plus vite possible aux
régions donc voilà qui a été fait et
donc comment continuer et aller plus
loin à partir de vos travaux nous nous
pensons qu'il faut renforcer et vous
avez raison sur l'analyse les régions
pilotage et politiques de l'emploi c'est
vrai que la meilleure territorialisation
la meilleure coordination des différents
intervenants est une chose attendue je
ne crois pas aujourd'hui qu'on puisse
dire que tout fonctionne parfaitement
mais il faut aussi savoir que ce que je
disais sur la formation professionnelle
et cette nouvelle organisation n'est
effectif que depuis le 1er janvier et
nous sommes au moin de mai vrai alors je
trouve extraordinaire que vous que que
on ne prenne pas en compte le fait que
janvier février mars avril c'est court
pour pouvoir tirer bilan de ce que nous
avons fait et avant même de tirer bilan
de ce que nous avons fait nous
réécrivons déjà notre histoire on me
disait tout à l'heure il y a peu de
temps on a voté une loi pourquoi la
réécrire c'était à propos de l'économie
sociale et solidaire là il y a encore
moins de temps et il y a encore oui il y
a pareil vous avez raison monsieur le
rapporteur
euh nous nous sommes en train de
continuer une loi qui ne s'applique que
depuis le 1er janvier donc j'entends
bien les critiques des régions
concernant le siège supplémentaire des
choses de ce type on l'a parfaitement
entendu d'ù l'écriture que nous avons
défendu à l'Assemblée nationale
permettre qu'une délégation de l'État
aux régions des missions de coordination
de certains acteurs du service public de
l'emploi puisse être faite c'est une
avancée vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure monsieur Delbard avec une
convention qui définissent objectif et
moyens qui regarde aussi les résultats
il faudra que nous ayons à cœur de
suivre justement cette évaluation et
enfin transférer aux région des
dispositifs d'appui à la création à la
reprise entreprise pour par les
demandeurs d'emploi c'est ce que j'ai
entendu le plus souvent demander en
particulier par un certain nombre de
personnes qui ayant subi un licenciement
économique ont envie de reprendre des
activités parce qu'il il y a compéten et
il y a marché et puis aussi parce que
nous savons que la création d'entreprise
par les demandeurs d'emploi est une
chose qui fonctionne assez bien et qui
fonctionnera mieux je pense que le Sénat
a raison et que l'assemblée l'a suivi si
on transfère ces dispositifs d'appui à
la région pourquoi parce que la la
région va effectivement mieux connaître
les secteurs économiques aujourd'hui
encore en tout cas c'est ce qu'on lui
demande et c'est ce qu'elle va faire
donc voilà ce que moi je voulais dire à
la défense de cet amendement et au rejet
d'un certain nombre d'autres je ne
reprendrai pas la parole souvent mais la
coordination des opérateurs du service
public de l'emploi c'est pas une veain
proposition et je conclus en rappelant
qu'effectivement si vous n'aviez pas eu
cette initiative il n'y aurait pas eu
d'initiative il y a eu une initiative il
y a eu suivi d'initiative il y a eu un
texte et je défends donc ce texte en
espérant recueillir un certain nombre
d'avis positifs de cette Haute
Assemblée merci Madame la Ministre
amendement 455 rectifié monsieur hon
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet amendement propose de
revenir à la formulation de l'article 3
bis adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pas trop dans mes habitudes mais
je veux simplement quand même rappeler
que il était prévu dans cet article que
la Région participe à la coordination
des acteurs au service de l'emploi sur
son territoire et pour le vivre cette
parfois aussi l'avantage d'être éclairé
par la pratique sur notre territoire je
continue de penser que la coordination
exclusive par la région pourrait avoir
et même aurait pour
conséquence la division du service
public de l'emploi pour l'emploi au
niveau national et les outils
territoriaux pour la région Maison de
l'Emploi Plans Locaux pluriannuel les
plis et puis lesmissions
locales et je pense que cela aurait des
conséquences néfastes à l'optimisation
du service public de l'emploi et que ça
porte en soi le risque de d'aller à
l'encontre des efforts de cohérence de
coordination qui sont menés sur les
territoires par Pôle emploi et les
outils territoriaux pour lesquels
aujourd'hui encore un certain nombre de
collectivité notamment
d'intercommunalité se mobilise je vous
donnerai simplement un exemple dans mon
département meurisel dans le sud du
département il y a des dispositifs
intéressants autour des maisons de
l'emploi pour lesquels aujourd'hui les
collectivités participent
majoritairement financièrement à ces
dispositifs et à cet instant je veux
quand même appeler notre attention tout
effort financier tout effort d'insertion
tous les efforts convergents qui
conduisent à remettre un certain nombre
de gens éloigné de l'emploi qui n'ont
pas de boulot c'est qui sont au
chômage j'estime que nous n'avons pas le
droit de nous prer des efforts conjugués
ce sont les efforts pour la France et ce
sont peut-être aussi et d'abord les
efforts pour des femmes et des hommes
qui sont sans emploi et bien nous savons
que les temps sont difficiles mais même
s'ils sont difficiles je dirais même à
plus forte raison nous devons redoubler
d'efforts y compris par un
accompagnement financier social et
humain c'est d'abord le respecter la
digneté de ces personnes et je pense que
ça va dans le sens de l'engagement des
femmes et des hommes qui se mettre au
service de leur pays pour ces raisons je
pense et en tous les cas je souhaite que
vous soyez que cet amendement soit suivi
vous avez vu que un certain nombre
d'entre nous c'est peut-être pas
conforme en tous les cas à ce que la
Commission a pu décider mais j'en
appelle en tous les cas à à votre
sagesse générale et surtout au sens du
soutien en direction de ceux qui de
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
d'emploi et qui grâce à ces dispositifs
de coordination le
retrouvent merci Monsieur hon amendement
rectifié pardon pardon pardon pardon 480
d'abord excusez-moi c'était collé les
feuilles monsieur sidau pardonnez-moi
monsieurè merci madame la
Présidente les élus des départements
proposent que la région préalablement à
toute décision dans le domaine de
l'emplo sois des personnes en situation
du handicap puisse recueillir l'avis du
Conseil Départemental des personnes
handicapées appelé à devenir le conseil
départemental de la citoyenneté et de
l'autonomie qui sera présidé par le
président du conseil départemental selon
les termes du futur article
l1-11-1 du code de l'action sociale et
des familles eu égard à la spécificité
que présente la réinsertion des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
le milieu professionnel et des
compétences sociales du départ
le présent amendement vise à assurer aux
personnes handicapées un traitement
efficace de leur insertion ou de leur
introduction dans un emploi adapté aux
particularités de leur
situation merci Monsieur Sid
l'amendement 381 rectifié monsieur
reier cè c'est même esprit que précédent
si vous voulez puisque donc il s'agit de
préciser que la région donc pr la marche
à toute décision dans leain de l'emploi
des personnes handicapées doit
recueillir l'AVE du conseil
départemental personnes handicapées
voilà je serai bref pour gagner du temps
merci Monsieur requier avis de la
commission sur ces amendements monsieur
le rapporteur s'il vous
plaît alors l'amendement du
Gouvernement je remercie madame la
ministre d'avoir fait part de des
évolutions qui
manifestement sont nécessaires dans ce
domaine alors la réflexion est peut-être
pas aboutie c'est pour ça vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre de de choses
honnêtement même si la formation
professionnelle c'est nouveau raison de
plus pour mettre tout de suite la
coordination de l'accompagnement vers
l'emploi en même temps parce que c'est
lié les deux choses c'est lié vous savez
très bien que l'emploi ça dépend aussi
de la formation et et et et pour les
demande s'il y a pas de formation bah
c'est plus difficile d'avoir des emplois
et je pense que on a donné une
compétence économique
au aux régions donc c'est c'est la
logique vous savez en 83 84 on on s'est
on s'est pas contenté de donner une
compétence on en a donné plusieurs aux
régions surtout au département et puis
d'autres lois aussi la loi d' trfarin
donc on on peut c'est que qu'il y ait
des délais que tout ça ça se mette en
place que ça soit un peu compliqué oui
mais si on trace pas
une si on trace pas une orientation on
fera pas grand-chose parce que tous les
conservatismes seront là pour
l'empêcher et vous savez avec mon
collègue Ren von nous avons reçu tout
tous J'ai ét tous alors je vais pas les
citer tous les organismes multiples et
on s'est dit mais c'est formidable il
travaill même pas ensemble chacun de son
côté chacun sa boutique c'est
formidableit pens on doit dépenser des
sommes colossales d'ailleurs la Cour des
comptes l'a dit à plusieurs reprisesin
enfin la Cour des comptes je sais pas si
on l'écoute souvent il faudrait les
écouter l'écouter pour faire des
réformes nécessaires et
donc on s'est dit mais c'est
extraordinaire que quand même la région
devienne le le le localement parce que
ça se fait pas au niveau de l'État c'est
pas vrai c'est pas
vrai devienne localement le coordinateur
vraiment de l'accompagnement vers
l'emploi tout en en respectant les
choses admirables qui ont été faites par
les uns et les autres nous on a une
ambition si on veut rester comme on est
tout va bien ça va certainement
s'améliorer nous croyons beaucoup dans
ce domaine à la à la place des des des
régions des élus locaux parce que ils
sont aussi des praticiens du terrain
voilà donc nous sommes Madame le
Ministre tout en reconnaissant les
efforts faits et même les améliorations
par rapport au texte de l'Assemblée mais
pour
l'instant en plus on va dialoguer encore
avec l'Assemblée nous tenons beaucoup à
l'amendement qui avait d'ailleurs je le
rappelle je le salue avait été déposé
par notre excellent collègue Savari
c'était au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales voilà je tiens à le le
rappeler parce que il avait beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet donc vous
comprendrez mon cher collègue Husson que
je ne peux être d'accord avec votre
amendement conttenu de ce que je viens
de dire
quant à l'amendement de Monsieur
sido
B oui mais est-ce que est-ce que c'est
le rôle de de la la mission des la enfin
la future puisque ça s'appelle ça va
changer la MDPH en fait est-ce que c'est
le rôle de la MDPH est-ce que c'est pas
autre chose puisque c'est
l'accompagnement social essentiellement
oui mais évaluation mais c'est c'est pas
c'est pas que je sache c'est pas MDPH
qui qui définit l'invalidité au travail
non non non non non non non pas ça le
taux non oui mais c'est quand même ça
qui est important vis-à-vis de l'emploi
alors
écoutez non mais je connais c'est ce que
j'ai dit mais la visée de la m de la
maison de du handicap c'est pas tout à
fait la
visée bon je dis si on commence à tout
mélanger ceci dit qu'on consulte je
pense que ça sera nécessaire de
consulter mais c'est peut-être pas la
peine de le mettre dans la loi parce que
si on met toutes les consultations
nécessaire je pense que c'est superflu
et surtout c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose la visée du département je vous le
dis autrement on risque de un petit peu
tout mélanger donc pour dans dans
l'immédiat je vous demande de retirer
votre amendement autrement je serait
défavorable alors pour résumer on est
bien d'accord un avis défavorable sur
659 idem sur le 455 rectifié idem sur le
480 et sur le 381 rectifié 391
rectifi défavorable aussi très bien
monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre oui comp
tenu de du dépôt de l'amendement du
Gouvernement je ne peux être favorable à
aucun autre amendement jusqu'au bout
d'ailleurs de de la discussion et j'aime
autant le dire tout de suite merci
Madame le Ministre
je vais mettre au voix ces amendements
donc le
659 du gouvernement y y a-t-il des mes
chers collègues je vais pas je vais pas
vous oublier donc nous sommes sur le
659 du gouvernement explication de vote
monsieur Foucher vous avez la parole
sans aucun souci je ne vous aurais pas
oublié
présidente simplement si j'ai bien
compris ce que disait le président yest
donc en définitive moi par exemple chez
moi j'ai mis en place d'une maison des
des services publics au service publics
euh je consacre 150000 € par an il y a
la mission locale il y a pour l'emploi
qui fait les permanences j'ai mis en
place un système avec le Conseil Général
et cetera tout ça s'est réuni pour
s'occuper des demandeurs d'emploi donc
je n'auraai plus à m'en occuper ça sera
plus moi qui gérai ça ça ser gérer par
la région et moi je mettrai plus un sous
dans
l'opération monsieur F disparaître mon
cher la question mon cher collègue le le
rapporteur va vous
répondre nous viendrons mon cher
collègue aux maisons des services
publics et cetera qui avait été
malencontreusement ass soir supprimé
comme ça c'est autre chose que la la
coordination des actions hein en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi c'est
autre chose ça veut pas dire du tout que
ces maisons des services publics vont
disparaître au contraire on va les
encourager et et et et et et ell figure
aux articles suivants ils pourront
comporter parce que faut bien comprendre
que nous ne voulons pas supprimer par
exemple enfin mettre ou bien faire
éclater pour l'emploi pas du tout mais
ce que vous faites dans un certain de de
de de lieux vous dites pour l'emploi et
dans votre maison des services publics
et puis il y a la maison de l'emploi
éventuellement et puis il y a peut-être
autre chosees hein il y a peut-être
d'autres services publics ou au public
mais ça ça continue mais c'est
indépendant de la compétence du
Département de pardon la compétence de
la région en matière d'accompagnement
vers l'emploi ça ne veut pas dire du
tout que toutes les initiatives locales
pour réunir les services publics et
rendre vive notamment dans les zones
rurales je dirais même que c'est une
responsabilité du département en matière
de solidarité territoriale ça rentre
parfaitement dans ce champ donc ça c'est
indépendant ce que nous avons ce que
nous vous
proposons c'est indépendant de des des
organisations qui existent et qui sont
extrêmement utiles sur le terrain merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur Savari
pour explication de
vote présidente simplement effectivement
pour clarifier dans ce que avait été vu
proposé par la Commission des affaires
sociales et repris par la commission des
lois était vraiment d'aller jusqu'à la
coordination hein du développement
économique la formation et cetera alors
se pose se pose effectivement euh dans
les territoires des situations
différentes puisque il y a mission de
l'emploi il y a les les maisons de
l'emploi les mission euh local et cetera
la coordination veut dire que à un
moment il faut rationaliser les coûts il
est important d'avoir un système un
petit peu plus efficace c'est pour ça
qu'il nous paraissait intéressant que
cette instance de concertation qui
s'appelle le créfop soit entre autrre
présidé par le président de région pour
coordonner ce sera je crois l'article 2
ex article 24 je pas combien il va
devenir maintenant mais sera coordonné
au niveau régional alors où se pose un
problème et je rebondis sur ce que
disait Jean-Jacques yest c'est
effectivement l'insertion
professionnelle qui est dépendant des
départements plus ou moins en tout cas
pour les bénéficiaires du RSA donc il
faudra bien dans le cas des grandes
régions que cette instance de
coordination s'appuie effectivement sur
les départements pour l'insertion
professionnelle des bénéficiaires de RSA
c'est une instance de concertation
qui doit se mettre sur pied et ce sera
une déclinaison de la politique
d'ailleurs de l'emploi sur le plan du
territoire et puis le problème de
l'insertion et la formation des
personnes handicapées alors Jean-Jacques
yest c'est bien la MDPH qui définini la
RQTH donc le le le le la
capacité
notamment à l'emploi et qui définit des
plans de formation avec les AG FIP avec
et cetera pour faire en sorte qu'il une
insertion de ces personnes handicapées
qu'elles puissent derrière bénéficier
d'un certain nombre de formation pour
aller vers l'emploi on a bien vu qu'il
faut être attentif hein puisque il y a
un taux de chômage dans les personnes
handicapées double de celui des
personnes qui sont pas en situation de
handicap c'est pour ça qu'il faudra
trouver la
conceration
nécessaire pour faire en sorte que tout
le personne ne soit laissé au bord du
chemin mais je pense qu'avec l'article
24 on arrivait à faire quelque chose de
cohérent qui fait que les conseils
départementaux ou les MDPH seraient
automatiquement quand même consulter
dans l'approche de leur
insertion me
semble-t-il merci Monsieur
Savari je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 659 du gouvernement je n'ai
plus de demande d'explication de vote je
le mets au voix qui est pour je rappelle
avis défavorable de la commission et
bien sûr un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le
455 rectifié de Monsieur Husson pas de
demande d'explication de vote un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 480 de Monsieur
sidau il est maintenu explication de vot
monsieur sido
oui j'aimerais bien je ne comprends pas
parce que je ne comprends pas le
rapporteur très honnêtement parce que le
handicap c'est une des compétences les
plus importantes avec l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des conseils départementaux
bien oui vous le savez bien entendu et
et donc c'est bel et bien par par le
biais de la Maison Départementale du
handicap la
MDPH que finalement la hche est accordée
avec un taux qui est fixé par la
Commission et naturellement c'est c'est
la Maison Départementale du handicap qui
connaît les handicapés bien je ne vois
pas en quoi la Région le Conseil
régional pourrait se passer de l'Ave de
la MDPH d'une part mais également du
conseil
départemental du conseil départemental
des personnes handicapées il s'agit pas
du conseil départemental tout court il
s'agit du conseil départemental des
personnes handicapées qui deviendra le
conseil départemental de la citoyenneté
et de l'autonomie une fois que la loi
sera votée donc voilà maintenant si la
région peut se passer de de tout ça ben
que la région d'ailleurs reprennent le
handicap carrément puis on en parle plus
donc j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien des
explications complémentaires de monsieur
le rapporteur avant de me décider sur le
retrait ou non de mon amendement
monsieur Foucher pour expli vot je
donner la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre je rappelle qu'avant la mise en
place des maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées le handicap était
géré par
l'État quels que soi les gouvernements
ce n'était pas satisfaisant les gens
n'arrivaient pas obtenir les dossiers ça
demandait des mois et des mois on a mis
en place moi je l'ai fait dans mon
département le 2è ou 3e la Maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
les gens ont afflué naturellement parce
que c'est organisé parce que ça
fonctionne bien et je crois et je crois
je suis de l'Ave de du président Sid je
pense que ce n'est pas gênant pour la
région au contraire d'avoir un certain
nombre d'informations je veux dire on va
pas avoir une double enquête il y a une
information qui sera donnée
préalablement que la région demandera
une information qui a été faite une
étude il y a a une évaluation il y a
tout cela on va pas avoir deux fois la
même chose je veux dire c'est une
économie à la fois de temps gagner une
économie financière autant faire
fonctionner en complémentarité ces deux
institution je crois que ça me paraît un
amendement de de sagesse et et
d'économie dans cette période de
difficulté merci Monsieur fouch madame
ministre
je voulais donnergum
supplémentaire à Monsieur Sid pour
éventuellement retirer son amendement
parce que vous voulez bien vous voulez
que qu' a une consultation très claire
des départements alors si vous reprenez
le décret 2014 155 du 16 septembre 2014
il a été pris après la loi du 5 mars qui
a institué le crfop ce décret dit dans
son article R 61 23 34 que je cite les
collectivités départementales ressort de
la région sont associés aux réflexions
et aux travaux conduits par le comité en
matière d'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en situation de handicap donc
vous avez totalement satisfaction déjà
par ce décret quoi qu'on fasse après ce
décret s'applique merci Madame minist
vous le
retirez le 391 rectifié qui avait été
défendu par Monsieur re les maintenu
monsieur rqu explication de
vote je trou de Monsieur Sid était
excellent comme il a retiré je retire le
mien je vous remercie nous passons au
494 rectifiés bis qui n'est pas soutenu
mais je crois que la Commission voulait
peut-être le reprendre j'ai cru vous le
reprenez très bien
euh donc il pr il portera le numéro
790 avis de la commission sur cet
amendement donc le
494 rectifié bis madame favorable
B si vous le reprenez j'espère qu'il est
favorable monsieur le rapporteur sinon
ça va faire des
ordres
gouvernement voilà qui deviendra le 790
amendement de la commission jeavais dire
là on double le le nombre de
représentants des régions c'est quelque
chose qui déséquilibre ce qui a été
décidé donc le gouvernement ne peut pas
être favorable
défavorable je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement 790 de la commission avec
un avis défavorable gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté trois amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 457
qui va être présenté par Monsieur
sido en l'état du texte la
représentation des collectivités se
limite à une représentation des régions
et un représentant de l'ensemble des
autres échelon de collectivité
territoriale cet amendement vise à
assurer une meilleure représent
représentativité de chaque échelon local
et à s'assurer que les leurs intérêts
soient bien pris en compte sans rompre
pour autant l'équilibre et la
représentation au sein du Pôle Emploi
tel est l'objet de cet amendement cecio
deux amendements identiques le
390 rectifié qui va être défendu par
Monsieur requier vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue Président mes chers
collègues il s'agit d'un amendement
rédactionnel dans la même logique que
nous avons défendu précédemment il à
coordonner les différents échelons
locaux concernés par les politiques de
l'emploi comme l'a reconnu madame la
ministre il faut améliorer la
coordination sur le terrain il s'agit
ainsi d'une simple mais salutaire
précision rédactionnelle qui permettra
d'assurer une meilleure représentativité
des échelons locaux et à ce que leurs
intérêts soient effectivement pris en
compte au sein de PO emploi merci
Monsieur requer monsieur sidau je le
considère comme défendu puisqu'il est
identique que c'est un repli je vous
remercie avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
oui nous proposons que la région prenne
des responsabilités en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
immédiatement nous dit celles qui n'ont
pas de compéten dans ce domaine et ben
il faut qu'elles y soient aussi si on
veut le mélange des gens en plus il y
aura une question d'équilibre du conseil
d'administration de Pôle Emploi on a dit
un représentant des autres collectivités
ça me paraît suffisant déjà le le
gouvernement sur deux représentants des
régions il trouvent que ça fait beaucoup
hein bon alors si vous en rajoutez un
ceci un cela non je pense que non mais
on peut mettre tout le monde dans tout
mais ou bien on accepte qu'on clarifie
les compétences des uns et des autres
c'est ce que nous souhaitons dès que on
donne une compétence et là c'est pas une
compétence qui est prise au département
ou réparti différemment c'est une
compétence nouvelle qu'on donne aux
régions bah laissons les régions au
conseil d'administration de Pôle Emploi
pourquoi allez-vous vous pourquoi
qu'est-ce que il y a pas de compétence
des départements dans ce domaine
il y a pas de compétence des interc dans
ce domaine il y a des associations qui
gèent tout un tas de choses comme ça
mais aujourd'hui c'est coordonné par les
services de l'État c'est pas coordonné
par les collectivités locales alors moi
je veux bien tout à chaque fois depuis
ce matin depuis même à chaque fois on on
rétablit des confusions et je vous
assure que nos concitoyens sont là de
voir que tout le monde fait tout et que
ça devient
incompréhensible voilà alors c'est une
c'est une manifestation mineure celle-là
parce qu'il y en a eu des quand même
beaucoup plus fortte mais néanmoins moi
je vous dis c'est pas cohérent avec ce
que nous a ne ça on on regretterai
presque moi je vous le dis d'avoir voulu
prendre des mesures de proposer des
mesures vigoureuses en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi pour les
régions et monsieur le rapporteur avz du
gouvernement
oui je je suis ce que dit le rapporteur
et j'ajoute au conseil d'administration
de Pô emploi on a cinq représentants de
l'État pour 1,6 milliards de financement
et les représentants des partenaires
sociaux qui apportent 3 milliards donc
qui a à équilibré les représentants des
salariés et les représentants des
des des patrons donc à la limite si on
fait rentrer les partenaires faut
peut-être faire rentrer aussi les
milliards dire qu'est-ce qu'on est prêt
estce que chacun des participant
contribuent là on a un problème de
représentation des financeurs 1 milliard
et demi et et 5 milliards ou je ne me
trompe pas et bon on fait rentrer les
représentants des régions contre notre
avis on multiplie par deux c'est déjà
des non financeur mais financement de de
l'accompagnement
là est-ce que les départements sil rent
sont prêts à
financer non donc je je pense que
veillons quand même à nos équilibres
veuillons n équilibr il faut pas que on
finisse par avoir les financeurs qui
soient minoritair au conseil
d'administration très bien donc je vais
mettre au voix monsieur
sidau je ne me permettrai certainement
pas de rappeler monsieur le rapporteur
jean-jacquesest puisqu'il le sait bien
entendu que les départements s'occupent
du
RSA
et alors dans R il y a de l'insertion
dans cette affaire là et l'insertion par
l'emploi il y aurait donc utilité
écoutez utilité pour beaucoup de choses
d'ailleurs que les départements que oui
les départements aill voir un petit plus
ce qui se passe à pôemploi sache un
petit peu ce que font les allocataires
du RMI et donc il y a
toute il y a toute cohérence à ce que
les départements il soi quelque part
monsieur vous maintenz votre am
vous maintenez votre amendement monsieur
Sid excusez-moi je nai pas vous vous le
retirez monsieur
requier pour explication de vote sur le
390 rectifiéés nous nous proposions
simplement de remplacer des autres
collectivités territoriales par chaque
niveau de collectivité mais mais ce que
disait monsieur le rapporteur c'est qu'
ce il faudrait pas qu'il les autres
collectivités qui soi donc donc il
faudrait euh que si vous un amendement
de supprimer ces lignes de référence aux
collectivités parce que elles y sont les
collectivités actuellement nous
simplement on précisé qu' est chaque
niveau représenté voilà c'est pour ça
que vous m'z pas répondu tout à fait à à
mon amendement merci Monsieur Requet
vous maintenez votre
amendement Tiz mais je bien le retirer
mais à ce moment-là il faudrait donc
qu'on supprime notre collectivité si on
suivit monsieur le rapporteur ma
question est très simple monsieur Requet
vous le retirez ou vous le maintenez il
est retiré monsieur sido vous retirez
aussi il est retiré je vous remercie mes
chers collègues je seraai obligé de
suspendre la séance aux alentours de
19h15 puisqu'il y aura la Conférence des
Présidents je vous propose que nous
essayons de finir l'article 3 bis donc
vous en êtes tous d'accord alors nous
passons à 8 amendements en discussion
commune le
389 rectifié qui sera présenté par
Monsieur requier
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues madame
ministre mes chers collègues lieu de
concertation le créfop le crfop c'est le
comité régional de l'emploi de la
formation et de l'orientation
professionnelle il a fallu que je
cherche parce que c'était pas évident
donc CEF assure à l'échelle régionale
l'articulation des politiques d'emploi
d'orientation et de formation
professionnelle CEF est une instance
dans la gouvernance est quadri partite
il est présidé conjoint ement par le
préfet de région et le président du
conseil régional ou leur représentants
ces missions sont bien connues il est
chargé des fonctions de diagnostique
d'études de suivi et d'évaluation des
politiques nécessaires pour assurer la
coordination entre les acteurs des
politiques d'orientation de formation
professionnel d'emploi et la cohérence
des programmes de formation dans la
région à lien avec le knphope le knphope
c'est le Conseil national les mêmes
choses afin de mener à bien ses missions
la composition du créfop intègre outre
le prof des région et le président du
conseil régional des membres nommés par
arrêté du préfet de région notamment des
représentants des organisations
syndicales de salariés et
d'organisation d'employeurs notre
amendement vise à rétablir les
dispositions adoptées par le Sénat en
première lecture qui permettit au
département au vu de son rôle de chef de
fil de l'action sociale personne ça ne
lui conteste et de garant des solidalité
territoriale de siéger dans cette
instance de de
coordination monsieur requier amendement
identique de Monsieur sidau
oui il est défendu mais je veux donner
quelques explications quand même et donc
effectivement c'est les comités
régionaux de l'emploi et de la formation
et de l'orientation professionnelle créé
par la loi du 5 mars 2014 relative à la
formation professionnelle ont pour
mission d'assurer la coordination entre
les acteurs des politiques d'orientation
de formation professionnel et
d'emploi les politiques d'insertion
ainsi que les Plans Locaux d'insertion
pour l'emploi les le pli les missions
locales et les maisons de l'emploi sont
bien souvent portées par les élus
départementaux c'est pourquoi il
convient de rétablir les dispositions
adoptées en première lecture au Sénat
relative à la composition des créfop
effectivement et en les complétant afin
de permettre au département de siéger au
même titre que les élus régionaux et les
élus des groupements de commune merci
Monsieur sidau le 30 rectifieré ter
monsieur pelva
monsieur
Savari monsieur grand
vous oui vous êtes cignataire aussi si
vous voulez le
défendre monsieur grand celui qui veut
celui qui est cignateur peut défendre
l'amendement oui et puis on pourrait
faire aussi les les de les deux
sousamendements qui qui pour faire
gagner du temps hein donc il s'agit donc
de rétablir la la participation des
présidents des grandes intercommunal éé
métropole au sein de ce fameux créfop
euh donc ça c'est mon premier amendement
le
sous-amendement donc je défend micouot
pardonnez-moi ce n'est pas un
sous-amendement vous le 31 rectifie bis
c'est ça c'est un amendement ce n'est
pas un sousamendement voilà il vise donc
dans dans l'hypothèse celui-là serait
pas adopté à assurer la la
représentativité des métropoles et enfin
euh s'il est toujours pas adopté on on
propose un autre amendement de repli qui
la possibilité de candidater
c'est-à-dire donc de présenter ses
candidatures voilà très bien je vous
remercie donc il y avait un amendement
et deux amendements de
repli en revanche le 218 rectifié bis
n'est pas soutenu il était identique le
219 non plus et le 220 non
plus très bien avis de la commission
s'il vous plaît monsieur le rapporteur
sur ces qure amendements madame id je
vais être extrêmement bref je crois que
j'ai déjà expliqué que si on a une
compétence on siège si on n pas de
compétence on siège
pas parce que pour mettre tout le monde
alors maintenant les métropoles
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont comme
compétenence en matière de formation
professionnelle d'orientation et cetera
rien les intercommunalitir rien et mais
pourquoi voulez-vous mettre tout le
monde dans ces commissions régionales
qui sont des commissions d'orientation
et justement c'est pour parce que il y a
la formation professionnelle parce que
il y a il y a l' emploi qui est une
responsabilité jusqu'à présent de qui
reste une responsabilité de l'État c'est
de pour se concerter pour les programmes
et cetera ça n'a rien à voir franchement
si vous voulez
tout clarifier renoncer à vos
amendements parce que si c'est pour être
dans des des comités écoutez en plus non
ah non c'est pas un comité théodu le
comité régional parce qu'ils prennent
des décisions et ça engage des finances
ça engage les finances de la région et
les finances de l'État ça n'est pas rien
mais en plus mes chers collègues pour
avoir
l'expérience d'innombrables nominations
des représentants des collectivités
locales dans tout un tas
d'organismes ils n'y vont même pas parce
que moi non non hein mais non quand
monsieur quand le président sidau dit ah
il y a beaucoup d'élus départementaux
qui sont dans les missions locales ou
les maisons de l'emploi c'est évident
mais c'est parce que que sont des gens
reconnus mais c'est pas escalité de
conseil général c'est pas excalité non
ça n'est pas excalité on a des maires on
a des moi j'ai j'ai la Maison de
l'emploi c'est la députée maire qui est
présidente de la mission non la mission
locale c'est la députée maire qui est
présidente mais c'est pas parce qu'elle
est députée c'est pas c'est pas parce
qu'elle est maire elle a été élue par
tous ceux qui financent d'ailleurs
l'essentiel des collectivités l'état
mettant un peu d'argent passez je le dis
au passage mais c'est comme ça donc je
vous comme pour les autres amendements
je vous demande de les retirer surtout
plus encore plus au crpof parce que le
crpof c'est vraiment une instance de
décision de concertation entre la région
déjà aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui
puisque la formation professionnelle est
de compétence de la région et l'emploi
qui est compétence de l'État à laquelle
on veut mieux associer la région ça se
justifie encore moins de mettre tout le
monde voilà je vous vraiment je vous
demande pour la clarification des choses
de retirer vos
amendements du
Gouvernement c'est une
demande pardon oui c'est une demande de
retrait d'autant qu'il y a déjà 40
personnes ça va faire 120 130 150 que
sis et on aura même pas le quorum donc
c'est aussi pragmatiquement je pense là
qu'il faut rester raisonnable très bien
merci Madame la
Ministre merci Madame la Ministre donc
je vais les mettre au voix j'ai des
demandes d'exlication question de vote
donc sur le 389 rectifié il est retiré
monsieur sidau le 480 pour explication
de vote
oui pour dire que si au fond
l'amendement avait toute raison d'être
pratiquement étant donné que ces régions
sont démesurées et que on nous dit qu'il
y a 500 km ou 400 km entre le nord de
telle région et le Sud personne n'ira
bien entendu et pour que l'argument de
Madame la Ministre est excellent pour
qu'il ait le Corum et bien je retire mon
amendement bien je vous remercie les
deux amendements sont
retirés donc l'amendement 30 rectifié
terre y y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur
grand monsieur le
rapporteur on va voilà bon je je je sais
pas ce que vous avez contre les
métropoles mais je j'ai un peu de mal à
imaginer qu'on ne siège pas nos
métropole l'emploi c'est notre affaires
prioritaires nos métropoles s'occupent
de l'emploi nos métropoles investissent
pour l'emploi nos métropoles financent
pour l'emploi donc vous ne voulez pas
qu'on y siège moi je veux bien mais
regardez ce que nous représentons
regardez notre poids regardez notre
engagement donnez-moi une bonne raison
pour lesquelles nous voilà alors moi je
vous dis oui peut-être pas en formation
professionnelle mais en ce qui concerne
l'emploi nous y siégeons nous nous nous
sommes des acteurs déterminants d'emploi
et dans ma région monsieur dans mon
département où il y a 20 % de chômeurs
est-ce que vous croyez que la métropole
n'a pas son mot à dire sur la politique
de
l'emploi posez-vous la question de
savoir pourquoi il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé en Espagne parce qu'il y
avait on nous dit c'est parce qu'il y a
24 % de chômeurs nous on est à 20 % donc
aujourd'hui il faut simplement qu'on est
présent à l'esprit que partout où on
peut être dès lors qu'on parle emploi
nous dans les métropoles nous voulons y
être Madame le Ministre peut-être que
vous pourriez faire une propos
qui serait celle de dire que vous allez
décider vous pvez faire un amendement
vous avez tous les moyens et que vous
décidiez par décret comment seront
composé comment la composition de cet
organisme mais à mon sens les métropoles
ont leur place dans cet organisme merci
Monsieur grand monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez moi je veux bien tout je veux
bien tout vous me démontrerez parce que
si on emploie le si on
emploie le terme d'emploi dans des
raisons dans dans des modalités
différentes les métropoles ont un rôle
éminent en matière de développement
économique qui apporte l'emploi non non
mais veuillez m'excuser c'est quand même
moi si vous me montrez que dans les lois
sur les métropole on dit la compétence
et de la métropole la compétence
entendue aujourd'hui en matière pour
l'emploi et cetera et toutes c'est c'est
c'est tout ce qui est financé par l'État
ça n'est pas le cas mais oui mais je ne
suis pas plus contre les métropoles que
contre les départements vous le savez
bien ou les autres
intercommunalités écoutez j'étais
monsieur chers collègu vous n'étiez pas
encore
sénateur oui bah chacun a ses
faiblesses moi aussi j'en fus alors bon
mais mais monsieur j'ai défendu les
métropoles beaucoup plus que d'autres ex
à condition qu'on en limite le nombre
parce qu'autrement ça n'a plus de sens
et je le répète tout ça parce qu'il faut
le répéter de temps en temps mais j'ai
défendu les métropoles j'ai défendu la
métropole bien plus intégrée la
collectivité
spécifique la métropole de Lyon bon
après les autres ça va plus c'est plus
compliqué bon arrêtons-nous là bon et
puis on verra bien le la suite mais on
va revenir dessus mais je vous assure
que c'est pas contre les métropoles je
me dis d'une
manière un peu logique celui qui est
compétent siège celui qui n'a pas de
compétence ne siège pas parce
qu'autrement c'est la confusion et vous
le savez bien puisque vous êtes un
parlementaire expérimenté vous avez été
maire et cetera hein voilà vous le savez
bien plus il y a désignation dans tout
un tas d'organismes les gens n'y
viennent plus ah ou ils sont lassés
toute façon de tout ça il y a personne
on narrive même pas à réunir c'est trop
important cette affaire là pour que on
concentre bien sur les les acteurs
vraiment et ceux qui financent la
formation professionnelle et l'emploi
c'est pourquoi je vous demande de
retirer votre amendement merci madame la
ministre il a le rapporteur qui veut
aussi la parole peut-être vous prendre
en dernier monsieur le rapporteur pour
achevez de
convaincre mon
collègue et ilut
je je commençais par voyez me mettre en
scène en tant que élu de la métropole
lilloise j'ai passé une bonne partie de
ma vie à à plaider la prise de
compétenence plan
d'insertion par la Communauté urbaine de
lillele elle l'a pas fait d'unkererque
l'a fait donc c'est assez simple suffit
pas de dire je suis une métropole ça se
passe sur mon territoire
alors donnez-moi un siège au CA il faut
être titulaire de la compétence voilà
c'est
tout madame la ministre pour juste une
précision parce que il faut aussi que on
soit très clair moi la création
d'activités économique aboutit à la
création d'emploi rôle des métropoles
connaissan et cetera mais la politique
de l'emploi c'est l'accompagnement des
personnes qui sont en recherche d'emploi
ou qui sont en convertiss donc les
métropoles on leur demande de nous vers
le haut sur le relèvement de la France
depuis un moment donc de créer de
l'activité économique donc de l'emploi
regardez la structure gouvernementale le
ministre de l'économie n'est pas le
ministre de l'Emploi ce sont des
politiques publiques de l'emploi c'est
d'accompagnement voilà je crois qu'il y
a peut-être aussi cette confusion la
politique de l'emploi c'est très
particulier c'est très codifié et donc
je pense que vous pouvez retirer votre
amendement mais alors sur la métropole
allez-y faites créer de l'emploi de
l'activité économique des entreprise
c'est votre boulot quoi pardon c'est
votre travail merci merci madame la
ministre il est retiré son les trois
sont retiré je vous remercie amendement
454 ils sont retirés monsieur ah ben
allez-y allez-y allez je vous donne la
parole monsieur rberg allez-y ça va être
bref rassurez-vous madame la Présidente
mais je voulais approuver tout à fait ce
que disait les rapporteurs tout à
l'heure je crois que
d'expérience pour présider encore
d'ailleurs une on de l'emploi un pli et
une mission locale les politiques de
l'emploi là je crois qu'il y a une
confusion entre les politiques de
l'emploi et de formation professionneles
les politiques de l'emploi elles doivent
être territorialisées au plus proche des
instances de décision et que sont les
communautés les grandes
intercommunalités les métropoles c'est
une évidence mais là effectivement
siéger dans un organisme régional au
contraire je dirais c'est éloigné
l'instance de décision je peux vous dire
franchement d'expérience ce dont on a
besoin madame la ministre ce dont on a
le plus besoin aujourd'hui c'est de
donner le plus d'autonomie possible aux
directions territorial de Pôle emploi et
c'est là effectivement que tout se joue
par convention et on peut en signer des
conventions avec tous les organismes et
tous les acteurs du territoire et là on
peut faire du vrai boulot je ne pense
pas que ça soit en siégeant au
crfop merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je vais maintenant passer à
l'amendement 454 rectifié monsieur
Husson pour le défendre
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'ai l'impression qu'on y
revient mais moi en même temps j'ai
quelques j'ai quelques difficultés à à
voir et surtout à
imaginer ce que deviendront bientôt ces
maisons de l'emploi ces DISP de PL qui
va financer et quelque part comment sera
assuré la coordination donc je ne vais
pas en rajouter je vais simplement
redire ici que l'amendement que j'ai
déposé et qui est cossigné par un
certain nombre de collègues vise
simplement inscrire la participation des
représentants régionaux des
représentants
régionaux des présidents de maison de
l'emploi et des plis en tant que
membbres de droit descetfop ce qui
paraît logique puisqu'il
Figur au niveau national lorsqu'ils sont
dans le réseau Alliance ville emploi
dans le knnéphope donc dans le
parallélisme des formes il me paraît
logique pour pas dire normal de
permettre de siéger au dans les créfop
voilà pour les les personnalités que
j'ai évoqué à l'instant merci Monsieur
Husson avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui alors Monsieur hon a
raison de de penser que il serait
souhaitable que là où ils sont vivants
parce que c'est peut-être pas homogène
sur tout le territoire au même niveau
non non mais c'est pour ça que il
peuvent mais madame mais je suis désolé
mon cher collègue c'est réglementaire
parce que si on met tout dans la loi
quand il y a des modifications il faut
tout changer donc c'est réglementaire
mais je pense que madame le ministre
devrait pouvoir s'engager à dire bah non
mais non parce que c'est pas c'est pas
de nature législative la liste des
membres qui peuvent être dans le c'est
c'est de nature réglementaire par contre
je pense qu'il est utile de préciser que
là où ils sont ils existent bien et où
ils sont actifs il faudrait alors
d'ailleurs je sais pas comment ils sont
désignés les représentants mais enfin
tout ça c'est c'est c'est c'est du
réglementaire donc je suis défavorable à
l'amendement parce que c'est pas de
niveau législatif mais bien entendu je
souhaiterait que votre que votre volonté
d'être représenté soit bien
écouté monsieur le
rapporteur Madame le Ministre ou c'est
pris en compte dans le décret
d'application donc effement
réglementaire et ce sera pris en compte
donc il y a pas de souci monsieuron vous
maintenez votre amendement non parce que
il était temps j'ai bien fait de rester
avant 19h15 madame la Présidente vous
allez presque pouvoir sur ce moment un
peu historique où je remercie d'ailleurs
le rapporteur de sa bonté et surtout de
la parfaite connaissance des textes donc
je retire cet amendement puisque j'ai
compris qu'il était satisfait retiré
merci monsieur je vais donc mettre au
voix l'article 3 B je n'ai pas de
demande de parole je le mets au voix qui
est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
adopté article 3 TER 725 rectifié Madame
le Ministre
oui j'ai déjà donné l'explication madame
la président que je me suis permise de
le donner puisquil a été défendu avis de
la
commission
alors l'amendement veut réintroduire
dans la rédaction issue des travaux de
l'Assemblée l'article 3 TER le
gouvernement souhaite maintenir le rôle
de l'État comme principal acteur du
service public de l'emploi tout en
renforçant la place des régions si les
objectifs entre le Gouvernement et la
commission sont identiques les modalités
pour y parvenir sont
différentes ce qu'on a voté à mon avis
rend contradictoire et donc l'article de
l'amendement nous nous ne pouvons qui
être défavorable mer si monsieur le
rapporteur donc avis défavorable de la
commission il n'y a pas de demande
d'explication de vote je n'en vois pas
donc je vais mettre au voix qui est pour
cet amendement 725 rectifié avec un avis
défavorable de la commission je n'en
vois pas qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 3 TER
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient l'article 3
est
adopté nous en arrivons à l'article 22
oocè je suis saisi de deux amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
à l'article 22 octiè monsieur Dantec
pour le
634 oui on va on va peut-être pas être
trop long dans le débat je pense qu'on
l'a déjà eu assez assez
largement c'est ce qui ce qui est
intéressant depuis une semaine c'est
d'essayer de de comprendre où vous
veulent en venir les les uns et les
autres je voudrais dire en défense de
cet amendement que je crois profondément
à la commune je je pense que dans ce
pays la la commune est culturellement
extrêmement inscrite dans notre
perception du du du territoire et dans
notre vie collective et que et que donc
la commune même si si je sens un certain
pessimisme de certains voir un début de
nostalgie la commune n'est pas menacée
dans ce pays elle n'est absolument pas
pas menacé dans ce pays c'est un un
espace très identifié c'est un espace de
proximité de de solidarité et et donc ça
n'est pas le débat ce qui est menace la
menace aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
le sentiment de nos compatriotes de ne
pas être traité à égalité quel que soit
l'endroit où ils habitent C'est ça la
vraie menace dans dans ce pays et à
partir du moment où le bassin de vie
c'est s'est imposé comme plus grand
qu'au moment de la Révolution ce qui est
normal on a inventé depuis la voiture on
a inventé plein de choses on vit plus
exactement de la même manière évidemment
ce ce bassin de vie doit être géré par
une entité politique c'est un peu de
chos près
l'intercommunalité mais le système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui fait que dans ces
intercommunalités généralement le le
débat sur les grands les les grands
choix de l'intercommunalité au moment
des élections municipales est plutôt un
débat qui a lieu d'abord pour ne pas
dire des fois exclusivement dans la
commune centre et qu'un certain nombre
de communes périphériques membres de l'
intercommunalité et notamment les plus
petites n'ont pas le même débat au
moment des municipales parce que le mode
de scrutin n ne crée pas l'égalité entre
les citoyens le scrutin direct pour
l'interco c'est un enjeu démocratique
fort c'est un enjeu de perception
différente des espaces et de l'égalité
républicaine c'est ça l'enjeu ça
n'empêchera pas que la commune
continuera d'exister comme espace de vie
comme espace démocratique parce qu'elle
est ancrée culturellement mais si on
n'avance pas sur le scrutin direct et je
trouve que là-dessus l'Assemblée avait
quand même marqué une avancée
importante alors on va continuer de
nourrir le sentiment de relégation c'est
ça l'enjeu du scrutin direct aujourd'hui
et je je pense qu'il y aura peut-être
quelques interventions pour dire altela
vous voulez la disparition de la commune
ça n'est absolument pas le débat je
pense que c'est en dehors du débat et
c'est une manière de ne pas répondre à
la vraie question qui est la question de
l'égalité des citoyens par rapport aux
grands choix qui sont décidés dans
l'interc merci Monsieur pour le
rectifié merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues en
application de l'article 54 de la loi
maptam les conseillers métropolitains
seront élus au suffrage universel direct
lors du prochain renouvellement général
des conseils municipaux les modalités
concrètes seront fixées par la loi
électorale avant le 1er janvier 2017
l'article 5 4 4 de la loi maptam
prévoyait que cette loi se fonde sur un
rapport d'évaluation des élection
communautair de 2014 qui n'a jamais été
produit puis sur un rapport remis par le
Gouvernement au Parlement avant le 30
juin 2015 afin de présenter les pistes
envisageables ces délais sont
extrêmement contraignants et à ma
connaissance ils n'ont pas été tenus
sauf si monsieur le ministre nous
annonce que la remise du rapport du
Gouvernement au Parlement se fera bien
avant le 30 juin bon cet amendement
propose donc de repousser là encore
soyons pragmatiques ne donnons pas des
ultimatums que nous ne sommes pas
capables de respecter donc cet
amendement propose donc de repousser au
31 décembre 2015 6 mois de plus la
remise de ce rapport tout en élargissant
son champ d'étude à l'élection de tout
au parti des conseillers métropolitains
au suffrage universel
direct avis de la
commission sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Dantec je me
retrouve dans un débat que nous avions
déjà eu hein sur la loi
MAM donc qui a fait l'objet de la part
du Sénat et de la commission des lois du
même avis défavorable et je vais
pour que ce soit bien clair je vais vous
raconter une anecdote à la communauté
urbaine de
Lille c'est pas le groupe des veres
c'est pas le PS c'est pas
le le
groupe UMP et cetera qui travaille le
plus le groupe qui travaille le plus
c'est le groupe qui fédère les les
maires des petites et moyennes communes
et j'en veux pour preuve que au moment
de la mise en œuvre de la loi
Chevénement ils se sont réunis pour
savoir bah quel serait le devenir
euh de l'intercommunalité qui était dans
l'exemple que je prends la communauté
urbaine et bien ils étaient arrivés ces
maires à la conclusion suivante
un il faut sauvegarder ce qui fait la
légitimité c'est-à-dire le suffrage
direct par la population pour désigner
le maire
2 l'intercommunalité c'est de la
coopération intercommunale
3 si un jour se posait la question
d'avoir un autre mode de représentation
de le PCI on était et là je vous avez
tourné autour on était amené à se poser
la question d'une sorte de bicamérisme
local avec une avec une assemblée des
maires ou de leur représentant fléchés
par le suffrage éventuellement un autre
collège qui serait élu au suffrage
universel direct depuis baladure tout le
monde mélange tout là-dedans prenez le
problème comme vous voulez et je je
propose au Conseil constitutionnel de
regarder la question pour faire ça il
faut une révision de la Constitution
point barre donc faisons pas des faux
débats des débats de positionnement qui
sont euh véritablement
des l'heur des l'heur
voilà sur cette question très sensible
le Gouvernement s'en remet à la sagesse
du
Sénat monsieur baotrel a demandé la
parole pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues l'instauration du
suffrage universel direct pour la
désignation des conseillers
communautaires est un des sujets
récurrents en matière de gouvernance
territoriale de la France et de façon
sous-jacente il a été au cœur de nos
débats dans ce projet de loi nôre à
travers
l'évocation de la place et de
l'existence des communes dont
quelques-uns persistent à penser
monsieur le ministre et à dire qu'une
volonté gouvernementale plus ou moins
occulte chercherait à faire disparaître
la justification d'une telle disposition
relative à cette désignation serait de
nature selon d'autres à introduire
davantage de démocratie dans cette
sphère
intercommunale j'observe à ce sujet que
des associations citoyennes et des
particuliers posent ouvertement
désormais cette question ce rapportant
aux responsabilité et à l'incidence
fiscale et budgétaire de
l'intercommunalité dans la vie publique
une telle mesure contribuerait sans
doute à rendre le fonctionnement de ces
institutions moins abstraite qu'elle ne
le paraît actuellement aux yeux des
citoyens qu'on accepte cette idée ou
qu'on la rejette la question se posera
dans l'avenir avec une acuité accrue la
question est jugée du moment opportun
d'engager le débat et de mon point de
vue parce qu'il s'agit au vrai sens du
terme d'un débat de fond il ne peut-être
question de le trancher en catiminiie
dans une sorte d'entre soi sans
approfondir la discussion et sans
examiner précisément chacun des
arguments qu'une telle question emporte
et c'est justement parce que ce travail
politique doit être précis et approfondi
que j'estime que le moment n'est pas
celui-ci laissons aux intercommunalités
le temps d'assimiler les modifications
de périmètres et leslargissement des
compétences qui découleront du du Pr du
présent projet de loi c'est donc pas sur
le bien fondé ou non de cet amendement
sur l'article 22 opè que je me
positionne mais sur son opportunité
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas d'écarter
le débat mais de rechercher la cohérence
et à cette les sénateurs socialistes
estiment qu'il est préférable que cette
question soit dissociée du projet de loi
nôre et fasse l'objet d'une discussion
dédié c'est pourquoi nous ne voterons
pas cet amendement merci mon cher
collègue monsieur Savari a demandé la
parole
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement moi je partage les propos
qui sont tenus qui va-t-on voir quand il
y a un problème on va voir le maire
véritablement c'est encore le symbole
avec son conseil municip MP c'est le
symbole d'une organisation d'une âme au
niveau des communes donc arrêtons de
vouloir la détruire je crois que à
travers la campagne qu'on vient de mener
des départemental on a vu l'éloig le
sentiment d'abandon de nos campagnes et
sans sentiment d'abandon vous ne feriez
que que que
l'accentuer un moment où on est en train
de revoir la coopération intercommunale
hein qui doit être un outil au service
de nos concitoyens pour certains
investissements et certains services
publics rendre ce ensemble qu'on
pourrait pas faire seul et bien je ne
crois pas que ce soit le moment de
changer complètement la société parce
que c'est un vrai fait sociétal et je
partage le point de vue du rapporteur
moi c'est un problème constitutionnel le
département la région les communes sont
inscrites directement dans la
Constitution et donc on voit bien qu'on
a remis en cause ces périmètres ça
voudrait dire que nos concitoyens qui
sont déjà éloignés derrière ils vont
élire un président d'une
intercommunalité qui va être avec les se
de 20000 habitants dans des secteurs
comme les miens des communautés qui vont
rassembler 20 30 40 50 60 70 communes
par endroit quoi donc véritablement il y
aura plus d'attache dans un milieu rural
particulièrement difficile donc cette
solution est particulièrement mauvaise
moi je m'opposerai pour l'instant à
cette conception qui pourrait se voir à
condition que les intercommunalités et
les mêmes compétences or vous faites
élire vous proposez des lire des
intercommunalités qui ont des
compétences différentes et puis ensuite
vous les mariez avec des compétences
qu'il va falloir retravailler donc il y
a du prix au jour d'aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce type d'élection ça peut
s'envisager s'il y a une réflexion
profonde d'aménagement du territoire et
ce qui veut dire qu'on réorganise les
répartitions de compétences mais de
façon très fixe par rapport à la
structure Inter commmunale et je pense
que les esprits ne sont pas encore mûs
ça ne doit pas être un amendement au
décours d'une loi de répartition ça doit
être vraiment la réflexion partagée hein
et on doit trouver ensemble la solution
permettant droite et gauche confondu de
trouver une meilleure organisation mais
je pense que pour l'instant vaut mieux
rassurer nos concitoyens qui connaissent
un certain nombre de difficultés et ne
pas en rajouter monsieur le Président
mard
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues moi je
je suis atterré non pas que cette idée
soit émise parce que toutes en
démocratie toutes les idées peuvent être
émises et méritent d'être examiné mais
je je suis atéré hein qu'il y ait une
volonté affirmé de remettre en cause des
fondements qui René vandiren donc l'a
dit à très juste tout à l'heure
résultent de la Constitution nous avons
la commune le département et depuis pas
très longtemps la région comme
collectivité territoriale les
intercommunalités connaissance n'en sont
pas une ça c'est c'est déjà le le
postulat de base et je rappelle en tout
cas c'est ce qui ressortait de la loi
chevenénement que les intercommunalités
elles n'ont elles ne n'ont de compétence
qu'à la suite de décision de transfert
de compétences soit par la loi qui leur
donne des compétences obligatoires soit
optionneles et alors considérer hein
qu'on peut élire des conseillers
communautaires au suffrage universel
hein il faut imaginer quand même en
restant dans le même système et sans
réviser la Constitution et sans faire
une 4ème gauche parce que c'est c'est ce
à quoi vous vous vous arriveriez
qu'est-ce que ça donnerait sur le
terrain vous voyez des exécutifs
d'intercommunalité élu hein et puis d'un
autre côté hein les maires et et
adjoints élu d'un autre pas forcément
les mêmes et pas forcément pour faire
les mêmes choses mais c'est c'est ce
n'est pas en l'état quelque chose de
réaliste et moi je dois dire à collègues
socialistes que j'entends la sagesse de
notre collègue bautrel mais je suis en
désaccord total et mon groupe sur le
fond parce que vous dites que vous
renoncez à ça pour une question
d'opportunité mais que vous êtes en fait
d'accord sur le fond et c'est ce qui a
été voté par l'Assemblée nationale et
Ben et et vous et vous le redit et je
suis très content que vous le disiez
parce qu'au moins ça confirme ce que je
dis ici depuis des jours et des jours
c'est que
votre véritable objectif c'est bien la
suppression mais si c'est la réalité
mais si bien sûr que bien sûr que si
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
mettez je vous l'ai lu hier dans
certains rapports que la clause de
compéten génér de compétence générale
doit être transféré aux
intercommunalités et qu'il doit y avoir
une élection au suffrage universel il
faut il faut dire les choses alors si
c'est ce que vous voulez vous le dites
clairement en vote et puis on se ensuite
chacun respectera le vote majoritaire
mais ce que vous voulez et nous le
savons nous le savons c'est ça et bien
assumez-le parole est à Monsieur yest
oui c'est
inépuisable et nous sommes en 2e lecture
et à la fin d'un texte où on a déjà
débattu toutes ces questions-là
l'intercommunalité on en a débattu
longtemps c'est intéressant de relancer
toujours les mêmes débats
alors d'une part
juridiquement les conseillers
communautaires et grâce au Sénat sont
élus au suffrage universel mais dans le
cadre communal pourquoi oui mais
pourquoi c'est très important ça veut
dire qu'il représente leur commune dans
une intercommunalité il n'y a pas parce
que votre système c'est une
supracommunalité c'est tout c'est simple
et et et c'est constitutionnellement
impossible aujourd'hui alors cons
de de débattre tous les 6 mois de nous
mettre des des amendements à l'Assemblée
en disant on pourrait avoir un rapport
ou je sais pas quoi qu'est-ce que peut
dire le rapport bah il veut rien dire du
tout bon c'est pas ça la question ou
bien on dit bah après tout la parce que
vous croyez il y a deux systèmes c'était
d'ailleurs envisagé dans les années
71 la loi marcelain on regroupe les
communes on regroupe les communes
d'autres pays l'ont fait
hein c'est concevable la Belgique me
disait René vyen elle a fait 10 ans
avant elle a décidé que bah non mais bon
ils ont non mais c'est un choix on n pas
fait ce
choix-là donc arrêtons de de de de de de
dire les choses ce que vous voulez
imaginez mon cher collègue vous dites on
veut pas on n'en veut pas aux communes
que des conseillers communautaires etlu
directement soi-disant ayant les
compétences déléguées par les communes
parce que c'est encore ça
pourrait très bien ne pas être élu
conseill municipaux et décider dans leur
coin belle organisation pour la France
ce qui fait la richesse enfin de
l'intercommunalité c'est d'avoir les
conseils les maires les conseils
municipaux se réunissent parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils peuvent faire des choses
en commun que c'est plus c'est
théoriquement source
d'économie
théoriquement on y viendra peut-être un
jour parce que une baisse des dotations
donc il y aura forcément des économies
euh parce que c'est comme ça he en fin
de compte hein c'est le plus simple hein
pour faire faire des économies bon à
condition de pas tuer la bête
avec en la privant de nourriture et de
boisson mais
donc mais franchement moi je trouve
qu'on arrête de de faire des
élucubrations aujourd'hui de même que
quand on voulait supprimer les
départements il fallait une révision
constitutionnelle de même le jour où on
voudra faire des des intercommunalités
élu au suffrage universel direct dans le
cadre supracommunal il faudra faire une
révision constitutionnelle et alors on
me dit oui mais la Constitution dit
qu'on peut créer d'autres d'autres
collectivités prévues par la loi oui
pour faire la métropole de Lyon pour
faire la métropole de Lyon parce que
c'est des cas on l'a fait aussi outrem
bon parce que c'est des communautés
c'est des des des spécifiques mais on
peut pas faire une généralité alors bon
on va peut-être pas continuer pendant
2h ceux qui sont pas lassés du débat
peuvent continuer mais franchement on a
tout dit on a tout dit hein sur ce
sujet mais je vous assure en tous les
cas que c'est ça été alors vous c'est
l'habitude he monsieur dek on le
respecte beaucoup parce qu'il a eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de persévérance
s'il pouvait avoir un peu plus de
persévérance aussi parfois dans la
discrétion ça serait
parfait je pense que autres sont moins
discrets et plus non non mais dans la
discrétion pour relancer toujours les
mêmes
débatséta
seés mais je le diraiis aussi aux autres
le moment venu de vous inquiétez
pas monsieur
Nère monsieur le Président yest on n'est
pas lcé par cette discussion parce que
c'est une discussion de fond tout
simplement et le président mard tout à
l'heure a très bien expliqué où était le
problème
ah il est d'une part constitutionnel
vraisemblablement mais c'est pas ça le
principal c'est pas qu' soit
constitutionnel ou pas c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire effectivement des
communes quel est la vision que nous
avons des communes dans ce schéma
aujourd'hui et bien notre collègue qui
remonte régulièrement nous avons eu ces
discussions pendant des heures et des
heures pendant la loi où nous avions
trouvé un
équilibre qui paraissait acceptable et
accepté d'ailleurs par tout le monde et
là vous remettez le couvert de nouveau
qu'est-ce que vous voulez au fond au
fond ce n'est pas un changement de
niveau c'est un changement de nature que
vous voulez de fait de fait au bout vous
ferez disparaître la commune parce
qu'elle deviendra une coquille vide et à
partir du moment à partir du moment où
ferez disparaître les communes vous
frait disparaître ce qui constitue une
tradition et je remonte à la Révolution
et même avant quelque chose ce noyau de
base sur lequel nous avons toujours tous
été très
prudents je suis premier vice-président
de la première métropole qui a été créé
en France et bien comme le disait le
rapporteur tout à l'heure ce sont les
mares qui ensemble parce qu'ils sont
élus au suffrage universel non
contestable qui font en sorte d'orianter
les débats et personne chez nous
personne chez nous regrette ce système-l
ce système justement qui a fait l'objet
d'un accord général dans la loi maptam
alors pourquoi cette provocation
supplémentaire pourquoi vouloir mettre à
mal l'avenir des communes la question
vous connaissez la réponse aussi bien
que moi tout à l'heure le collègue vous
l'a dit vous voulez un changement
complet et finalement la disparition des
communes et bien nous sommes contre
parole est à Monsieur
ctonbach on est toujours dans la
caricature les méchants qui veulent
supprimer les communes voilà moi
j'accuse pas je n'accuse pas certains de
vouloir rien changer et d'être plus
conservateur que les Pier conservateur
c'est le débat accepter que des avis
soient différents moi je ne soutiendrai
pas l'amendement de Monsieur dantc ça a
été très bien dit par notre collègue an
Barel le groupe socialiste au Sénat et
pour l'accord qui a été passé sur la loi
maptam les mopole au suffrage universel
direct et les autres EPCI on reste sur
le système qui a été mis en place
fléchage pour les conseils communautaire
et pour les conseils de commune on reste
sur le système qui a été voté et cetera
maintenant je voudrais quand même
répondre à Monsieur yest qui nous
explique que c'est pas possible
constitutionnellement voilà je voudrais
quand même rappeler qu'une métropole
c'est un EPCI celle de Lyon est
particulière mais les autres ne sont pas
particulières ce sont des EPCI et
pourtant la loi prévoit bien qu 2020 les
conseillers seront élus au suffrage
universel direct donc moi je ne crois
pas qu'il y a un obstacle constitionnel
il y a aujourd'hui une situation
politique qui fait que en effet il faut
rester sur ce compromis ne pas aller
au-delà et être raisonnable mais je ne
vois pas d'obstacle constitionnel sinon
l'obstacle constitionnel c'est le même
pour les métropoles qui sont des EPCI et
pourtant en 2020 on élira les
conseillers métropolitain au suffrage
universel direct je note en passant et
j'ai bien compris l'intervention de
Monsieur yest qu'il trouverait
complètement anormal qu'un élu
d'opposition dans une ville puisse
diriger une métropole et mais je suis
d'accord avec vous ce serait pas
forcément quelque chose de très positif
et je suis sûr que Monsieur trouvera une
solution pour empêcher ce type de dérive
contraire à la
démocrati donc voilà donc le groupe
socialiste je le répète est pour le
maintien des communes nous ne sommes pas
pour leur disparition nous sommes pour
des évolutions nous sommes pour
favoriser l'intercommunalité parce que
nous pensons que des inter fortes
permettront la le développement des
petites communes et que la meilleure
manière d'aider les petites communes
c'est bien d'avoir des intercommunité
forte que maintenant sur le mode de
scrutin nous souhaitons rester au mode
de scrutin actuel et que nous
n'envisageons pas d'évolution du mode de
scrutin donc je le dis s'il vous plaît
monsieur mzard Mesdames et Messieurs les
élus de la droite républicaine évitons
les faux procès et allons au faux des
choses parole est à Madame gourau madame
la Présidente
gourau
non mais moi je m'exprime parce que j'ai
écoutez depuis j'ai pas pris la parole
depuis ce matin donc je peux m'exprimer
une fois en plus je suis seule
représentante de mon groupe donc je me
sens dans l'obligation de prendre la
parole il y a le président qui préside
bien
sûr moi je voulais dire plusieurs choses
d'abord je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit René Viren donc tout à
l'heure il faut savoir si on change de
système ou pas voilà si on reste sur
l'idée de ce que je vinement appelaé les
coopératives de communes ou si
effectivement on change on fait des EPCI
euh des collectivités territoriales euh
à part entière alors moi je suis un peu
embêté personnellement de cette sagesse
que vient de donner euh le ministre sur
cet amendement je vais vous dire
pourquoi
euh quand on me dit euh dans mon
département
le on veut le gouvernement veut dans la
loi ne faire disparaître les communes je
dis mais non on me dit mais si il y a
l'élection au suffrage
universel direct et il y a 36000
communes qui est distribué par Monsieur
Colomba qui fait évidemment qui va dans
ce sens et je dis mais l'amendement qui
avait été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
n'était enfin je dis plus exactement le
suffrage universel n'était pas dans le
texte du
gouvernement je dis donc voilà moi je
fais confiance puisque ça n'est pas
c'est un amendement qui a été apporté
par des députés bon et qui est passé
parce qu'il est passé parce qu'il y a eu
une majorité au moment où il il était
présenté mais je ne crois pas c'est mon
argument que le gouvernement veuille
cela alors la
sagesse
de du ministre
m'inquiète est-ce que c'est puisque le
directeur de la DGCL en plus a tout un
paquet de chemises vertes devant lui
est-ce que c'est pour faire plaisir au
vert ça c'est une première première
supposition
ou est-ce que sur le fond il pense que
c'est que c'est cela qui doit être fait
et et moi je voudrais en conscience
quand je défends une position dans mon
département ne pas défendre une position
qui ne soit pas au fond celle je fais
confiance au gouvernement en disant cela
mais si le gouvernement passense le
contraire
ça me mettrait en porte à fau et je n'ai
j'ai horreur d'être en porte à fau donc
monsieur le ministre vraiment je
voudrais que vous me redonniez
explication sur ce sujet parce que le
jour moi j'ai je me souviens à l'époque
où j'étais vice-président de
l'Association des Maires on avait même
réfléchi à un système où on laissait les
élections des délégués des communes
comme c'est aujourd'hui dans un système
communal on avait même réfléchi Jacques
pélissar était assez favorable à
l'élection d'un président au suivrage
universel direct je sais pas si vous
rappelez on avait même à une époque
réfléchi à ça donc tout peut s'envisager
tout peut évoluer tout peut se modifier
mais au fond moi je je voudrais être sûr
que la parole du gouvernement est fiable
pour qu'on ne se trouve pas en porte à
faau dans la défense que l'on fait au
fond du gouvernement quand on est sur
notre terrain monsieur le Président B
demander la
parole
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
il y a manifestement entre nous dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'être pragmatique et de
faire fonctionner nos collectivités
territoriales des zones de consensus et
c'est heureux il y a aussi des points de
clivage et j'ai bien le sentiment que
ces points de clévage sont absolument
irréductibles parce que les
perspectives dans lesquelles la majorité
de l'Assemblée nationale s'est inscrite
sont des perspectives qu'en vérité le
Sénat dans sa
majorité ne peut
accepter il y a une sorte
d'analogie avec ce qui a été fait il y a
maintenant 33 ans un tiers de siècle
exactement avec les régions au fond
quand la loi de
1972 a créé les établissements publics
régionaux elle a conçu les régions comme
une sorte de syndicat interdépartemental
la région c'était par le moyen d'une
mutualisation la poursuite de l'action
départementale sur la base d'un
partenariat
entre
départements quand en 1982 on crée une
collectivité territoriale on prévoit
alors de les lire au suffrage universel
direct et la région change de nature et
on crée cette emboîement de collectivité
qui depuis le tournant du 21e siècle
fait débat entre Français et vous a
amené et je m'adresse au gouvernement et
à sa majorité à envisager la suppression
des départements pour répondre à cet
emboîement qui à certains égards pouvait
paraître excessif vous avez compris
depuis cétait pas la bonne solution mais
quand nous avions envisagé le conseiller
territorial au fond nous avions cherché
un compromis qui permettait sans revenir
sur la naissance des collectivités
territoriales régionales d'exprimer
notre souci d'une osmose entre les
départements et les régions les régions
étant mises au service en quelque sorte
des projets départementaux et devant
réaliser une sorte d'arbitrage entre
départements pour faire jaillir un
intérêt supradépartemental mais en
cohérence avec les départements et voilà
que un tiers de siècle après avec une
certaine constance dans l'idéologie et
euh je ne peux vous la reprocher vous
essayez de faire nettre au niveau
supracommunal ce que vous avez réalisé
en 1982 pour les régions
c'est-à-dire un découplage progressif
par le moyen du suffrage universel
direct entre commune et intercommunalité
et c'est ceci que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter car pour nous
l'intercommunalité c'est l'instrument de
la poursuite de la politique municipale
en lien avec les partenaires
que les électeurs nous ont donné venant
des autres communes et c'est la raison
pour laquelle ce qui nous différencie
sur ce point est absolument fondamental
car que vous le vouliez ou non la
concurrence que vous créez par le
suffrage universel direct entre commune
et intercommunalité ne pourra se
résoudre à terme que par le choix entre
l'une de ces deux collectivités c'est
pourquoi je vous supplie humblement de
renoncer à cette C approche parce que
vous ne pouvez pas comme vous le faites
dire que vous êtes favorable à la
pérennité de de l'institution communale
et créer cette forte concurrence qui à
l'évidence crée une
dynamique sur laquelle nous ne pourrons
pas revenir et c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur ce point précis dans notre
débat alors qu'il y a tant de sujet pour
lequel nous pouvons faire émerger un
consensus le clivage est de mon point de
vue absolument réductible
oui allez-y mon cher
collègue applaudir à demain ce que vient
de nous dire Philippe Bas il vient de
d'établir une une démonstration
éblouissante et je voudrais ajouter un
élément à l'argumentaire qu'il nous a
développé c'est l'argument de la
subsidiarité sur lequel les fondé sur
laquelle est fondé le fonctionnement
moderne de beaucoup de nos institutions
y compris en Europe et on peut souhaiter
que les institutions européennes
respecteront la subsidiarité y compris
des collectivités locales dans dans
cette affaire
euh revenir sur sur sur cette élection
des conseillers
communautaires au suffrage
universelle la proposé c'est renoncer en
fait à terme au principe de subsidiarité
et donc il faut bien y
penser peut-être que dans 6 ans ou dans
12 ans nos successeurs à la
lumière des évolutions institutionnelles
à venir au niveau européen au niveau
national et au niveau régional peut-être
que nos
successeurs reviendront sur les
arguments et sur les convictions que
nous développons aujourd'hui mais de
grâce je rejoins Philippe Bas faites en
sorte que les communes restent à leur
place et qu'ell puissent désigner les
délégués
communautaires de façon indirecte de
façon à ce que les conseillers
communautaires soient bien les délégués
des communes et que la et les
communautés de communes ne soi en fait
que les prolongements dans le respect de
la subsidarité le prolongement de la
volonté des il y a là une réelle
nécessité démocratique très actuelle
vous maintenez monsieur
DC oui je je vais maintenir l'amendement
je suis assez surpris par le temps pris
par ce débat très honnêtement c'est
amendement un peu
identitaire ça fait partie effectivement
du fonctionnement normal et si vous
regardez bien d'ailleurs j'ai pas abusé
des amendements sur cette deuxième
lecture il y en avait un nombre
relativement limité mais nous venons de
prendre plus plus d'une heure sur sur ce
débat et je en vous écoutant je me
disais mais mais pourquoi pourquoi ils
ont besoin de d'y revenir alors que le
débat a eu lieu qu' a peu de chance que
ça passe dans les minutes qui suivent
trouver une majorité dans l'hémicycle
donc il y a pas de de grand risque et et
je remercie vraiment Philippe Bas de de
son intervention parce que je crois
qu'il il donne la clé de de la raison de
ce débat et de la nécessité pour les uns
et les autres de de d'y revenir c'est
qu'effectivement nous sommes sur un
processus nous sommes sur un processus
et nous savons tous très bien ici que la
loi que nous allons voter est une loi de
compromis et est une loi sur un chemin
et que ce chemin ne s'arrête pas là
c'est pas une loi pour 20 ans qu'on est
en train de voter c'est une loi pour
probablement moins de 10 ans c'est et
c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça que vous
y revenez parce qu'effectivement il y a
une étape derrière et et l'exemple pris
en disant finalement à partir on a fait
de la région une collectivité de ple
exercice ça affaibli le département et
la suite logique c'est la fin du du
département ceci dit pour l'instant il
s'est quand même maintenu est une un
raisonnement assez intéressant et que
moi je trouve intellectuellement plutôt
stimulant il y a il manque juste un
élément il manque juste un élément dans
le raisonnement qui aujourd'hui qui
aujourd'hui dirait il faut supprimer les
régions qui dirait aujourd'hui les
régions n'ont pas de légitimité
démocratique c'est ça qui manque dans le
raisonnement c'est que demain c'est que
demain demain cet interco qui correspond
à la réalité de la vie quotidienne avec
un scrutin direct elle gagnera
évidemment aussi sa légitimité et
personne derrière n'y reviendra le vrai
débat et René virin donc la à mon avis
l'a ouvert de manière intéressante c'est
de trouver le mode de fonctionnement qui
permette de dire il y a scrutin direct
parce qu'il y a compétenence lourd et
dans un une démocratie moderne là où il
y a compétence lourde il y AR indirect
mais il y a une nécessité d'intégrer une
diversité territoriale qui correspond au
fait que là culturellement je le redit
la commune est un élément fort de
l'identité française à l'échelle de de
de chacun et que donc elle disparaîtra
pas et j'ai d'ailleurs déposé mais je
les ai pas redéposé là parce que je
voulais pas justement qu'on est qu'on
refasse le débat l'idée et qui et qui
est défendu aussi par le sénateur
Bertrand qui est défendu aussi par le
sénateur Bertrand à partir d'une entrée
d'hyper ruralité qui est que demain il
faudra peut-être deux chambres il faudra
peut-être deux chambres et
qu'effectivement on on est plutôt
aujourd'hui avec un sénat qui joue le
rôle du frein à main qui essaie de
ralentir ce qui finalement en filigram
de beaucoup d'interventions apparaît
comme inéluable mais moi je dis il faut
se cotiner vraiment la question c'est
quoi le fonctionnement deain avec une
interco qui est beaucoup plus légitime
démocratiquement c'est peut-être tê de
chambres moi je crois que
fondamentalement les deux chambres c'est
c'est quelque chose assez logique et
d'équilibré mais plutôt que d'être dans
le frein à main comme vous savez
finalement et c'est pour ça que vous
intervenez tous que tout cela est
inéluctable discutons-en sérieusement et
si on trouvait un consensus et ce
consensus passe par le fait que vu les
compétences des interco elles ne peuvent
pas se priver encore longtemps du
scrutin direct dans une démocratie
moderne la parole est à Monsieur
carucci monsieur le Président
sincèrement je comptais pas intervenir
dans ce débat passionnant mais comme
c'est open bar et que tout le monde
s'exprime plusieurs fois sur des
explications qui n'en sont plus
euh moi je je je vais vous
dire puisque notre collègue se demande
qui voudrait mettre un terme aux région
moi voilà dans dans dans le mode de
fonctionnement dans le mode de
fonctionnement actuel moi qui été un
régionaliste convaincu qui a défendu la
région en 2004 dans la Loire àfarin je
j'affirme aujourd'hui que ça ne
fonctionne pas voilà je le dis
tranquillement ça ne fonctionne pas je
préside une commission des finances de
la région île-de-fance je vous affirme
que ça ne fonctionne pas et qu'en
réalité l'éloignement des élus régionaux
par rapport à la réalité du terrain est
une horreur voilà ils sont et moi
premier hors solol complètement hors sol
et vous pouvez pas dire que ça
fonctionne et pardon monsieur le
ministre mais la création alors
l'île-de-fance n'a pas bougé elle est
déjà 12 millions d'habitants mais la
création d'autres très grandes région va
provoquer la même chose que sur la
région île-de-fance tant qu'on a créé
les régions on les a créé pour être des
collectivités d'investissement et
d'intervention c'était l'objectif
et l'objectif était de dire ces régions
avec de grands sujets d'aménagement ou
d'activité économique coordonnent
l'action des départements et font ce qui
réellement correspond aux régions à
l'intérêt global progressivement avec le
suffrage
universel progressivement la nature et
en horreur du du vide et puis les élus
se disant je suis élu au suffrage
universel j'ai des droits je veux des
compétences je veux des pouvoirs ir les
régions sont devenues des collectivités
de gestion de plus en plus lourdes de
plus en plus administrative de moins en
moins d'intervention et de moins en
moins forte et en réalité quand on
continue de dire comme ça parce que
c'est comme ça parce que depuis 10 an
c'est de bon ton de dire que c'est la
région qui doit ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas vrai autant je pense que la
région peut avoir une action forte d'
investissement de coordination de
l'action des départements autant quand
on donne aux régions qu'est-ce qu'elles
font elles émettent des règles elles
émettent des schémas elle parce que
comme c'est trop grand et bien on
n'arrive pas à gérer en direct et donc
on fait des schémas et on passe pour
comme en île-de-fance 6 ans à faire le
schéma régional de développement et on
passe 5 ans à faire le schéma
d'aménagement on passe des années à
faire des schémas qu'ensuite on essaie
des ment de faire voter par les Conseils
départementaux qui en veulent ou qui
n'en veulent pas la réalité c'est que
soit on revient à l'origine des régions
mais on y reviendra pas parce qu'avec le
suffrage universel vous avez créé des
élus qui se disent on n'est pas là pour
faire la coordination des département on
est là pour avoir des pouvoirs et si
vous faites des interc qui sont au
suffrage universel direct vous aurez la
même chose parce que par définition les
conseillers communautaires élu au
suffrage universel diront nous sommes la
les représentants du peuple nous devons
avoir le pouvoir et vous décaisirer les
communes comme les régions essayent même
pas volontairement mais mécaniquement de
désaisir les départements on n pas
compris dans ce pays qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire élire tous les niveaux de
compétences au suffrage universel sans
créer des demandes des pouvoir et une
volonté de pouvoir donc soit on dit
c'est la commune et le département qui
sont les collectivités fondatrices et à
partir de là il y a des organisations
autour de la commune des organisations
autour du département à part le niveau
national et ça a du sens soit on donne
le suffrage on met en place le suffrage
universel à tous les niveaux et vous
verrez que ça ne fonctionnera que de
moins en moins et de plus en plus
cher la parole la parole est à Monsieur
Mercier merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président un Huron qui viendrait non pas
au palais royal cette fois mais au
Palais du
Luxembourg visiter aurait de la peine à
comprendre le débat quand il lit
l'amendement de Monsieur Dantec parce
que quand on lit l'amendement de
Monsieur dantc bah il y a rien à faire
il est satisfait aujourd'hui les
conseillers communautaires sont élus au
suffrage universel direct dans le cadre
de la commune c'est vrai mais ils sont
élus au suffrage universel direct vous
pouvez tourner l'affaire comme vous
voudrez
donc su modalité particulière non mais
ça veut rien dire du tout simplement ça
ça veut rien dire et Monsieur Dantec
poursuit AB purement idéologique mais
qui ignore quand même
qui pour celle-là sûrement d'ailleurs
c'est en baisse quand on regarde les
derniers
sondages et
toutefois je crois que ce mouvement
idéologique ignore un peu les réalités
de terrain et quand on quand on voit par
exemple le mouvement en faveur des
communes nouvelles c'est pas forcément
que tout le monde veut supprimer les
communes mais c'est que les gens sont
attachés à la commune avec des
compétences particulières dans des
intercommunalités mais justement qu'on
ne veut pas voir disparaître les
communes euh moi je ve un peu partout
sur le territoire il y a toujours
plusieurs centaines de maires qui se
réunissent qui réfléchissent alors il
faut pas tous des communes nouvelles
dans les 20 secondes c'est évident mais
ils en font ils en font de plus en plus
et ils croient à la commune la commune
dans le cadre intercommunal a un rôle il
y a pas d'opposition entre les deux pour
l'instant l'intercommunalité certes elle
a de plus en plus de compétences propres
qui lui sont accordées par telle ou
telle loi la loi allure ou d'autres qui
interviennent mais ce sont des
compétence communal réalisé au niveau
intercommunal le conseil communautaire
il est élu au suffrage universel direct
alors peut-être que le mode de scrutin
vous plaît pas mais si j'ai bien compris
il y en a d'autres qui vous plaisent pas
et que le Gouvernement n'envisage pas de
changer tout de suite
notamment pour l'élection de députés que
vous réclamez régulièrement ah
bah mais je vois pas pourquoi j'ouvrirai
pas des débats qui vous divisent un peu
alors que vous essayez sans arrêt de
d'ouvrir vous-même des débats qui qui
n'ont pas leur place ici donc moi je
crois que cet amendement est largement
satisfait et qui nous appartient de
donner une vraie vie aux communes et aux
intercommunalités et aux
intercommunalités et que le reste
honnêtement c'est pas le moment monsieur
dantc le sait parfaitement il préfère à
la paix à la sérénité et à l'efficacité
des territoire un peu la pagaille parce
que là au moins ça ressemble à une trame
verte la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre à à l'invitation de madame
gourau je
vais préciser un peu la position du
gouvernement qui est très claire d'abord
par rapport à monsieur le président de
la commission des lois sur le conseiller
territorial
qui a été diabolisé par l'opposition de
l'époque qui ne méritait peut-être pas
d'être diabolisé à ce point mais qui
avait quand même beaucoup de défauts et
il faisait courir deux risques ce conser
territorial soit on allait assister à ce
que Monsieur Baladur lui-même souhaitait
d'ailleurs et j'étais membre du comité
Baladur c'est-à-dire l'évaporation des
département c'était le terme de Monsieur
Baladur il comptait sur le conseiller
territorial pour que les départements
s'évaporent dans les régions soit on
allait assister c'était plutôt ce que je
pensais à l'époque à une cantonalisation
des
régions je referme la parenthèse sur le
conseiller territorial sur le débat
relatif à l'intercommunalité et à
l'élection au suffrage universel des
conseillers communautaire ce n'est pas
un débat médiocre si autant d'entre vous
se sont exprimés avec beaucoup
d'arguments c'est que ce débat est
passionnant il est au cœur de de la
problématique de actuelle de la
démocratie locale et moi je partage
les interrogations qu'ont exprimé msieur
Dantec Kaltenbach Botrel sur la
légitimité qu'on les
intercommunalités qui lèvent l'impôt qui
sont renforcés de compétences toujours
plus nombreuses et plus importantes et
qui n'ont pas la légitimité que leur
conférerait une élection au suffrage
universel direct mais j'ajoute aussitôt
que le système actuel de fléchage leur
donne une légitimité beaucoup plus forte
que ce n'était le cas jusque- là et
j'entends les arguments de celles et
ceux qui sont opposés à une avancé dans
une
direction du suffrage universel cette
fois-ci pur et simple supracommunal les
inquiétudes qui se sont exprimé d'un
conflit de légitimité qui pourrait
exister entre les élus municipaux et les
élus intercommunaux supracommunaux
communautaires pour parler une langue
juridique j'observe d'ailleurs que ce
conflit légitimité existe déjà parce que
moi j'ai dans mon
département au moins un président
d'intercommunalité qui a été battu aux
élections municipales dans sa commune
mais qui siège dans l'intercommunalité
au titre des élus de l'opposition et qui
se retrouve et tant mieux pour lui
président d'intercommunalité donc ce
conflit de légitimité il existe déjà
dans tel ou telle communauté de commune
sauf que il n'est pas aussi aigu qu'il
pourrait l'être si ce président de
l'intercommunalité avait été élu
directement au suffrage universel là il
est élu mécaniquement si j'ose dire
comme élu de l'opposition de sa commune
donc voilà il y a des
arguments recevable des des deux côtés
si j'ose dire le gouvernement en tout
cas ne souhaite pas modifier la
législation actuelle s'il avait voulu
madame gourau aller plus loin il
l'aurait fait dans ce texte les députés
eux ont choisi les députés le groupe
socialiste pas le rapporteur le groupe
socialiste de l'Assemblée nationale a
souhaité ouvrir le débat je répète que
c'est un débat qui n'est pas médiocre
mais pour l'heure le gouvernement s'en
tient au système actuel et ne souhaite
pas changer la
législation bien bien bien qu'ils
étaient assez peu discutés je vais
mettre au voix les deux amendements 634
et
700 57
rectifié donc déjà le
634 amendement de Monsieur Dantec et des
groupes écologistes qui est
pour
qui est
contre abstention je crois qu'il n'est
pas adopté le
757 rectifié maintenant qui est
pour Monsieur
Nère qui est
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté
voilà pour les débats en 2ème lecture
des sénateurs sur le projet de loi à
notre nouvelle organisation territoriale
de la République un texte vous l'avez vu
il y a eu des débats fournis entre les
Atur et le gouvernement vous avez pu
voir et bien deux points de friction
principaux tout d'abord la politique
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi doitelle
être confiée à la région et bien c'était
là le point de vue des senénateur mais
pas celui du gouvernement également
deuxème point bien le mode de scrutin
des conseiller communautaire sur ce
dernier point finalement enfin dans le
texte final et bien les sénateurs ont
obtenu gain de cause vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires